[Music]
talk about James Cage white shoutouts to
our very lovely boy I like it I like it
very cool berry swag you could get a
shirt very cool very swag this is a
banana I like it I like it
bananas rewards they're yummy very good
I like apple I'm gonna show you cuz you
but speaking of the the eastern lands
where a good friend James Cage Y is from
we're gonna talk about an island where
my ancestors are from called Japan right
heard of it you might have heard of it
it's where they have vending machines of
dirty underwear they have noodles called
ramen and they have animate sounds fun
they have amusement parks there and
they're gonna start to reopen they've
been closed since February and
everyone's kind of like basically not
even enjoying their lives right now I'm
not even gonna go to Disneyland because
I'm scared but they said well we we are
gonna open and all of these theme parks
in Tokyo have been hit pretty hard like
Disney see Disneyland Universal Studios
there are two Disney's over there
Disney see I guess it's like there's
SeaWorld I don't know if they have
killer whales doing dance systems no but
yeah this is regular fish yeah cuz
they're like no we eat them we don't
know a big restaurant so huh
but what they're asking for is they have
guidelines right and if you all thought
that Japanese people were very calm and
quiet they're gonna be even more calm
and quiet because now they're asked not
to only scream on thrill rides but also
in shows and everything so they're not
allowed to scream at all that's not why
they already don't scream have you been
to Disneyland Tokyo No
right why it is roller coaster whoever
so it's like you're going through
everyone just for real like me and Bart
geo and say for the only ones go so
opposite to the states like the way that
they try to it's kind of like my mom
calls it like trash from humans not
translated very well but like so
introverts probably know this more than
extroverts but like you get too
emotionally exhausted by other people's
energy right so out there it's kind of
like just just like your hygiene and
your smell and all these other things
like you also want to restrain from like
being too much around people and
rounding them up so like that goes with
noise and talking too loud and like all
these other things that might affect
people around you is have all the
Japanese girls laugh like exactly they
cover up they don't want so it's not
just expressions of positivity but also
expressions of sadness and everything
it's like that's why they have cry rooms
or something get yeah you do these
things dude I gotta cut your pan you
should call me yeah it's fine for people
who are introverted and you love ASMR
and things like that cuz they pay
attention to those details yeah but when
it comes to an American who just wants
to go right you look around and you're
like what's wrong with y'all right so
that now plus the co vide what's
happening is like now when you're on
rides you got to wear the masks and then
cheering and all those things you're
just spraying all this [ __ ] in sorry
your honor roller coaster to theory
people in the front and it's going out
of the me you know what they say no
crying in the club I feel like that was
to me because every time I go into a
club I don't go very often but like it
like yeah I can't help it like it's too
much energy and I do cry I'm serious
swear to [ __ ] it last year on my
birthday I went to my favorite karaoke
club but usually I code in the middle of
week like on a Wednesday when it's kind
of you know low-key but this year it
fell on a Saturday we went I stepped in
the karaoke someone was like yeah they
were all singing in the stereo was right
here the speaker's not even logical I'm
like logically I know I shouldn't cry
just because it's loud it's just like
purely emotion there's too much energy
and vibrations and it just went out I
wish I could turn it off it's [ __ ]
weird I know I wish there was other
people that are like me too but I know I
did I mean ah well I feel safe in the
club for some reason like the noise
makes it feel like you're like yeah
absolutely didn't like this light energy
and you're like yeah I don't like that
but at my apartment like like when I
used to live that apartment yeah I
[ __ ] hate apartments now yeah never
grew up living in an apartment I grew up
in the house but when I moved out on my
own
hey an apartment like I don't know I
just I couldn't handle I hear my
neighbors I could I didn't know wasn't
was a thing and like [ __ ] like their
base I like it cuz there are a gentleman
home their garage opening on my would
thought [ __ ] I think maybe I'm moved by
people like you cuz when I was playing
TV 19 that loud it was like 8 o'clock at
night right and then I was just like my
hands like subwoofers my next-door
neighbours come and they're like hey we
can't hear ourselves read my friends
dude my brain she travels for days yeah
but they're like complain that they
can't hear themselves really buddy is
complain
I can't hear my own voice they're
[ __ ] to go with their books crying
like Nicky because of the there is this
dude that that next to us that goes
there's a parking lot next to our condo
and he blasts his music like it's a
[ __ ] concert and it drives me crazy
but that doesn't make me cry like
concerts for some reason they don't make
me cry someone's performing it's like
the crowd is all paying attention here
but when it's chaotic and everyone's
around each other and then like the
music is piling on top of that so you
can be at a club let's say you had your
own section
yes the lounge clubs okay I'm okay with
like if there was like a jazz singer and
like this lounging talked about a club
club yes you like Vegas for club yeah
but you gave it a Bible service because
you're doing I could do that I could
maybe do that if it's away from the
speaker's but she's gonna cry on the way
to the table though yeah or go to the
bathroom if I knew there was somewhere
safe to go it I can make it one of the
strip club was pretty loud when we went
but it's more orderly I wanted to go so
it would you be cool with the club if it
was empty like there's no people is it
the amount of people and body amount of
noise yeah it's really noise so you for
you loud noises just too much like hey
yeah just what are you guys what is not
organized noise it's like it's not
orderly like a concert it's like we're
all watching that and we're all cheering
for that I could be at a baseball game
or a football game and we're all
cheering for that thing but when it's
all around you and there's like so much
you like joint 11g yeah so it's like in
sync like if people are cheering
together their concert for a concert or
whatever yeah yeah yeah what about what
about a third grade band where
everyone's just playing their own [ __ ]
way together
warming up let's get back to you or no
one let me know what Tigers in third
grade
Nikki's in the auditors like crying it's
good pushing over a little kids the next
level thing that I thought was pretty
nuts is like so for meet and greets you
know how you go to like Disneyland and
you could get an autograph from like
Mickey and all this [ __ ] right so
they're not allowing any more hugging oh
no more shouting when you see your
celebrity Mickey or goofy or whatever
are they gonna wear masks it's like a
natural instinct like how they're gonna
shut the kids up that's hard maybe maybe
that's like when they keep them I don't
know how they do it but all the Japanese
kids out there form a line like a good
military oh they're already scared of
their parents the dad just goes yeah and
then you see a lifetime but they also
used to hang face masks I don't think
that would be an whoo weird and and I I
do think that like low-key though
they're kind of trolls out there so
everybody like the mascots would wear
the face mask and all that I mean I just
feel like a natural instinct on a ride
is to scream yeah true yeah you can't
contain it I've been on rides where or
like I was an inline and you know the
one that's addict captainship and they
just all I love that and we saw someone
throw up not to say people just dump the
people all the people able to start
hearing screaming like that so like that
I get how you can spread germs I read
through the sandlot huh I resume the
sanli all right when they do the spinny
spinny head chewing tobacco yeah
A virus by a regular roller coaster by
your yelling well I guess like they do
like talk or something it's supposed to
be it's in the air particles and then
that goes directly to the person it's
science
yeah you moved you're moving toward into
the germs that's a person in front of
you or if you're in a teacup ride you
just spitting it within your friends and
you're going whoa but if you're wearing
a mask and you're like oh but have you
ever had someone in the front seat like
spit out and it comes right into the
back seat of the car oh oh yeah yeah
it's probably like that I've done that
we don't get enough for sequels yeah
yeah you ain't gonna bastard I ever
smoked too fast maybe I don't know I
prefer just letting it all out though
like if I go on a rollercoaster I gotta
just Express and it'll scream and then I
don't know you know what come to think
of it I think I'm a silent roller
coaster right I am too I think I'm more
of a oh you're just afraid I'm afraid
not even on the roller coaster mr.
smiley cause he's watching like y'all
are crazy
great song just like [ __ ] I wanted to do
but once we go down I'm like maybe like
a quick and then I'm good
don't you feel more the g-force maybe
you don't scream really I I started
screaming because I was like this is way
more enjoyable because without screaming
I feel like I'm gonna die sound like
they're talking about sex
[Music]